Where We Are all right
and when I wake up plans for a black
panther sequel began in 2018 and then
shifted in August of 2020 when Star
Chadwick Boseman passed away from colon
cancer and Marvel decided not to recast
his role of t'challa now production was
only delayed by a couple of months
though and filming actually took place
throughout the second half of 2021 and
into this year wrapping up in March and
after being bumped from its original
July 2022 release date black panther
wakanda forever was officially moved to
November 11. along with being the sequel
to Black Panther this marks the 30th
film in the MCU and the final
installment in phase four now is
directed by Ryan coogler who co-wrote
the screenplay with Joe Robert Cole
holding the same roles that they did for
the first film also returning is Leticia
Wright who plays shuri t'challa's sister
and the princess of wakanda she was
given a larger role in the film after
Chadwick's death and she's joined by
others from the first film including
Martin Freeman deny Guerrera Winston
Duke and Angela Bassett
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ers
there's gonna be some fresh faces too
some of the new characters will meet
include Dominique Thorne as Iron Heart a
genius inventor with a suit of armor
similar to Iron Man Who also has her own
self-titled series coming to Disney plus
and this film marks the first
live-action appearance of Namor the
ruler of talikan now that's the primary
antagonist played by tenoch Huerta who
learned a Mayan language and how to swim
for the role fun facts as far as The
Story Goes we know that morning the loss
of King t'challa can't last too long
because telecan and other hostile
nations are trying to push wakanda to
the brink of War plus the change in
wakandan leadership could make some
waves assuming that the embassy's
t'challa and vision were built after
Avengers Infinity war that could be how
ironheart fits into things and would be
a great way to continue t'challa's
Legacy in the MCU but don't forget as
the final seconds of the new trailer
revealed there will be a new black
panther
there is a new world power
what contact will form
I think we're vulnerable
they're welcome to find out to learn
more about Black Panther and everything
coming to the MCU head to
rottentomatoes.com
[Music]